ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément loin de palm
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus se taire ils
ont des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité la
france oubliée c'est montrer ce qu'on ne
voit jamais
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je me rends à grenoble dans
la région rhône alpes
[Musique]
toi
bonjour émis merci donc c'est moi donc
là on est on est dans ta chambre eu ça
fait quatre ans que enfin c'est la
quatrième année que je finissais du coup
donc tu es étudiantes ou quelle
discipline chez en anglais du coup on
llc er donc ces langues littératures et
civilisations étrangères et régionales
et du coup en troisième année donc tu
veux te prof os je vais être chercheuse
du conflit nisation irlandaise et c'est
compliqué j'imagine quand on est
étudiant et qu'on n'a pas forcément une
famille derrière pour tous financés de
d'étudier on est obligé de travailler
c'est ce que tu fais toutes mes parents
m'aident un peu hauteur de leurs moyens
et puis après je travaille donc 15
heures par semaine c'est assez dur parce
que fo fa alliés en fait les études et
le travail et des fois c'est un peu
compliqué quoi tu as des tu fais quoi
comme suit dans la restauration du coup
dans un peu c'est un peu entre le fast
food et le restaurant classique c'est
quoi le budget moyen par exemple ici là
une chambre ça coûte combien ici c'est
366 je crois cette année donc par mois
avec toutes les aides que tu peux avoir
disons si gros bouillons tu arrives à
payer son loyer et c'est tout c'est ça
donc après il faut
se mouvoir faut se déplacer il faut
manger
il livre un pas que j'ai un peut avoir
une vie sociale culturelle même si sans
excès c'est ça ma du coup j'ai avec mes
quinze heures par semaine je touche à
peu près 150 euros par mois donc pour le
coup ça me permet vraiment de mieux
vivre donc de ne pas avoir à m'inquiéter
à la fin du mois pour la nourriture mais
sans ça par contre je pourrais
clairement pas en fait faire mes études
à grenoble
j'imagine c'est très compliqué de ne pas
décrocher du monde des études parce que
on est un peu livrés soi même il faut se
motiver on doit bosser on doit compter
ses sous bah clairement moi j'ai
décroché
c'est super dur en plus dans les
résidences ont internet qui est très
fluctuant on va dire donc les courants
zoom et ses terrasses et marche c'est
invivable ses bacchantes quand on entend
qu'un mot sur deux ou que où que ça
grésy etc
c'est enfin c'est horrible là
actuellement on n'a aucun contact avec
avec les gens on sait que notre diplôme
va avoir aucune valeur parce qu'on
n'aura pas assez bas pour ceux qui sont
à plus de 2e année plus de six mois
enfin presque six mois de cours en
distance yale et en plus bas enfin on
sait qu'on va pas réussir dans la vie on
fait avec ce qu'on a ce qu'on traverse
actuellement
parce que ya pas de travail à la clé à
la fin moi personnellement je me sens
abandonnée de la part du gouvernement
parce que parce que du coup on a assez
confinement etc
mais par contre toutes les aides qu'ils
ont pu dire les étudiants ont touché
cette aide là c'est tellement compliqué
a touché et c'est qu'en fait on n'est
absolument pas aidé c'est en fait on
nous a abandonnés en disant bon il ils
sont jeunes ils s'en remettront le
chaque année on a des suicides
d'étudiants ça on le sait mais là c'est
encore pire avec avec la crise qu'on
vient actuellement
tu t'es dit bon
je vais pas attendre que ça tombe du
ciel je m'organise on est quelques-uns
on va prendre les choses en main l'idée
de cette association de cette
association c'est ça c'est en fait ces
générations précarité c'est parti au
début en fait d'une pétition qu'on avait
lancé en septembre et on va voir les
gens quand ils rentrent donc je perds
marché en leur demandant bien voilà nous
on va redistribuer
est-ce que vous pouvez les aider à un
auteur d'un paquet pas vraiment c'est à
hauteur de vos moyens
on demande pas plus après en fait
justement pour nous c'est pas c'est pas
une solution qu'on peut garder sur le
long terme en faisant des restos du
coeur bis c'est une solution pour aider
au plus rapidement les étudiants en
attendant que justement les pouvoirs
publics mettre quelque chose en place
qui puisse les aider sur sur une durée
qui est plus longue et du coup en fait
faudrait juste valoriser le fait qu'un
étudiant
c'est un travailleur intellectuel mais
un travailleur est en fait presque avoir
un salaire pour les étudiants pour
qu'ils puissent en fait vivent
pleinement leur leurs études et se
concentrer dessus et donc pas avoir à
redoubler quatre fois parce qu'il
travaille à côté on va les voir
concrètement puisque là tu va distribuer
cette aide alimentaire dans une autre
cité u c'est ça donc là et demi on
arrive à une autre résidence
universitaire s'appelle le rabot c'est
là que tu viens régulièrement pour faire
de l'aide alimentaire c'est ça on essaye
de venir une fois toutes les deux
semaines
d'accord du coup on distribue à peu près
une centaine de personnes à chaque fois
le coup tu aurais de suivre ouais moi
aussi vous le guide
désolé j'avais fait que passer pardon
bonjour yes tout le monde est bienvenu
les gens souvent font la queue pendant
une trentaine de minutes et puis après
ici en gros on estime des quotas en fait
donc par exemple ça va être deux paquets
de pâtes des conserves limité à deux
souvent on va à l'étrier aussi entre les
légumes et la viande
voilà et puis après du coup il ya
d'autres produits des produits d'hygiène
protections périodiques va avoir surtout
en fait des étudiants du coup en
situation d'extrême précarité donc des
étudiants étrangers et des personnes qui
sont qui sont plus en contact avec leurs
familles merci facettes de ce côté tu
vas pouvoir choisir gels douche savon
pour les mains au dentifrice et en plus
tu peux prendre un rasoir embrassades en
coulisses avant merci donc ton prénom
c'est à dire il dire tu es originaire
donc tu originaire d'algérie shebab
tu es étudiant i686 informatique en
informatique et tu as comme beaucoup
d'étudiants chercher de quoi te nourrir
parce que la vie est chère c'est
compliqué personnellement je viens pour
avoir une aide beaucoup plus 1-1 parce
que j'y arrive quand même c'est juste
une aide financière d'accor voilà on
finit toujours la séquence par une photo
ok donc là comme il ya une belle eu
assez contrasté de la situation parce
qu'on pourrait croire qu'on est au
paradis terrestre il ya quand même des
problèmes et on va on va faire une vu
une photo la juste avec la ville
derrière je trouve ça plutôt sympa tu as
le droit de sourire et de respirer un
grand coup
superbe
[Musique]